-Our next guest is a very
talented comedian and actor
you know
from the film "Fire Island,"
the Showtime series
"I Love That for You,"
and the hit podcast
"Las Culturistas."
His comedy special,
"Matt Rogers:
Have You Heard of Christmas?",
premieres December 2nd
on Showtime.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Santa and Jesus ♪
♪ They were best, best friends ♪
♪ They knew each other ♪
♪ Way back in college
in Bethlehem ♪
♪ They knew each other
like ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ They were like,
"Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh" ♪
-Please welcome to the show
Matt Rogers, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
-I am so happy you're here!
-I'm very happy to be here.
-First-time guest on the show.
Not your first time
in the studio.
-That is correct.
I sat right about in the middle
over there.
We share a love
of the singer Kelly Clarkson.
-We do. We do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, we have some fans.
And I did get a friend
to, like, score me tickets
to your show one time
when she was on.
-Uh-huh.
-It was her "Meaning of Life"
album tour.
I came. I sat right over there.
And you go out into the audience
and do, like, a little Q&A.
-I do, yeah.
-So I thought
I'd be real funny.
And I was like --
I asked a question,
and it was this question.
"Hey, Seth,
Team Justin or team Kelly?"
And you were like, "Kelly."
[ Laughter ]
And sort of moved on.
And so that was the way
I met Seth Meyers,
which wasn't necessarily
how I wanted it to go.
This is much --
-Yeah, let's treat this
like our first.
-Well, I did used to say
on my podcast a bunch,
"Las Culturistas"
with Bowen Yang,
that you would be a dream person
to bring home to your parents.
-Oh, that's very nice
of you to say.
-I always felt that way
about you.
Like, if you brought him home
to meet the parents,
like, it's Seth Meyers.
You know what I mean?
And then you sort of crushed it.
[ Laughter ]
-Give me a chance.
I think I will --
If I ever meet your parents,
they will be very impressed.
-Exactly. Exactly.
-So, you have
this Christmas special.
-It's true.
-And you actually --
We were talking through
the commercial break about
the Rockefeller Center Christmas
tree, which is right --
You have a song about the tree.
-Yeah.
Well, so, some background on me
is I needed to sort of take back
Rockefeller Center
because I had a --
a screen test for
"Saturday Night Live"
that went sort of one way
for Bowen Yang
and another way for me.
-Mm-hmm.
-So then it kind of
made me sad to come here.
So I was like,
"I'm going to write a song
about Rockefeller Center that,
like, takes the power back."
And so I wrote a song
that's sort of about
what happens when you come here,
and it's, like, okay.
You know what I mean?
It's like...there's the tree.
-Yeah.
-We see it.
It's definitely big.
-Yeah.
You know,
if you're a size queen,
like, we love the tree.
But then
it's kind of just a tree.
-Yeah.
-Then you go to a restaurant,
and you have a burger.
It's definitely a burger.
-Yeah.
-Costs 45 bucks.
-Uh-huh.
-But so it was nice of me to
sort of drag Rockefeller Center
so that I can come back here
today a king.
-Take the power back.
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-You mentioned --
You mentioned king.
Mariah Carey, of course,
the Queen of Christmas.
-Yes. Good segue.
-You actually -- Thank you.
You reached out to her.
-I did.
-With the hopes
that she would anoint you.
-Basically, my special,
"Have You Heard of Christmas?",
is sort of me trying to join her
in the pantheon
of Christmas royalty.
-Of course, yeah.
-So, she's the Queen
of Christmas, as we know,
trademark be damned or not.
Like, she didn't get
that trademarked,
but that's who she is.
-Yeah.
-So I'm trying to become
the Prince of Christmas.
And I thought, like,
let's write her a letter,
try to get the blessing.
Maybe she'll let me
sing one of her songs.
She did not read it.
-Okay.
-I did not hear back from her.
But I hope that if she's
watching, she does read it
because
there's a good story in there,
which is when
I was in third grade,
I became very obsessed
with her "Butterfly" album.
-Okay.
-So this is like --
If any members
of the Lambily are here,
which is the Mariah Carey
fan community --
Okay. Maybe not.
[ Laughter ]
You know that the "Butterfly"
album is sort of when
she, like, discovered
her sexuality.
-Mm-hmm.
-And there's a song.
It's track four on "Butterfly."
It's called "The Roof,"
and it's basically about her
getting sort of, like, intimate
with Derek Jeter on a roof.
-Oh, wow.
-And the rain is slowly falling,
and it's a very sexy song.
And I memorized that song,
and during reading free time
in third grade,
I just wrote out the lyrics
to that song.
And it's really --
it's not for a third grader.
-Yeah.
-And then my teacher was like,
"Please hand in your journals."
And so I sort of, I guess,
go into, like, a fugue state
and hand in my journal,
and a few days later,
I guess she wasn't in
the Lambily like you guys.
And she was like, "Matthew,
your stories are so vivid.
[ Laughter ]
You are beyond your years."
Because I had basically said
everything that could happen
with Derek Jeter on a roof
besides Derek Jeter,
like, nailed me on a roof.
Which would have
been interesting
for my parents to hear about.
-I love -- I love --
-'Cause we were Mets fans.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Still are.
-You reveal a little --
some biographical details about
Mrs. Claus in your special,
and I feel like not a lot
of people have made an effort
to tell her story.
-They have not.
-I thought that was
so noble of you.
-Thank you for saying that.
And she has been --
She's been lost to time.
You know, she's this character
that we celebrate,
and, you know,
we're trying to draw out,
like, who this female character
of Christmas is.
And people don't know.
They know she's Mrs. Claus,
but they don't know
she's actually Kristen.
-Okay.
Oh, that's her first name.
-Kristen Giordano.
-Really?!
-Yeah.
She came from Syosset, New York.
[ Applause ]
Yes.
And basically I wrote a song in
my special which is sort of --
It's very much like
a Kelly Clarkson revenge ballad
about what happens when
she finally got a calculator
and crunched the numbers,
and there's no way her husband
is seeing every home
in 24 hours.
-Yeah.
-So where have you been?
-Right. Exactly.
We talk about -- in
"Las Culturistas" with Bowen --
can you talk about
where Christmas ends?
There's sort of three stages
of pop stardom.
-Okay. Right.
So basically, like,
in this special,
"Have You Heard of Christmas?",
this is me in my pop-star era
doing Christmas.
-Okay.
-So every pop star has, like,
a Christmas era, we all know.
They have two other eras.
There's circus, where a pop star
is sort of in a circus.
-Okay.
-There's "I'm angry about
surveillance and cameras."
-Oh, I see.
-Where -- Because of a result of
the success of the circus era.
-Yeah.
-The pop star then has to go
put the cameras away,
like, very --
-Seems very unfair for someone
who was just in a circus.
-Exactly.
-You can't be angry if people
are looking at you.
-But that's sort of
the narrative.
It's like, "I wanted it.
Now I don't want it."
And then when you calm down,
you do your Christmas era,
which is -- and, of course,
every pop star really
genuinely loves Christmas,
and they're not just trying
to make money off the holiday.
-Of course. They all naturally
come to their first love.
-Exactly.
Everyone, like, is dropped in.
They know what
they really want to do
is celebrate Christmas
every year.
And it's not about money.
It's not about money.
[ Laughter ]
-So, you saw "Titanique,"
which we're going to do next.
You saw the show
and loved the show,
and you're actually going to
help out with the introduction.
-I am. This is -- You guys
are in for a real treat.
"Titanique"
is the best live theater
you can see in New York
right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I'm really excited.
Just a cameo, I'd say.
-Just a cameo.
And one last thing.
That is very exciting.
You are also on
"Celebrity Jeopardy!"
-Yeah, "Jeopardy!" for babies.
-Okay.
"Jeopardy!" for babies.
-Yeah.
-Is it really?
How much easier would you say
the questions are?
-It's like,
"Where's America on a map?"
It's literally like,
"Is the ocean blue or red?"
And then you have to, like --
The hard part is the buzzer
'cause we all know
the ocean's red.
-Yeah.
-It's just about being able
to buzz in quickly.
-Right. I've heard from people
it's about --
You've got to time it
just right.
-Here's the thing.
It's, like, a thick buzzer
with a thick button.
And so if you're like --
You can't negotiate your hand.
Like, this is me
trying to do it.
-Yeah. So, did you win?
-I came in second place.
John Michael Higgins,
I concede to you.
And I crushed Aisha Tyler.
She didn't stand a chance.
-Well, that's very nice. Second
place is quite impressive.
-Exactly.
-Thank you for being here.
Thank you for sticking around.
"Matt Rogers:
Have You Heard of Christmas?"
Premieres December 2nd
on Showtime.
We'll be right back
with a performance
from the cast and musicians
of "Titanique"
with special guest Matt Rogers!